now the conflict in Yemen has created
what the U.N calls the world's greatest
humanitarian crisis the International
Community has been trying to convince
all parties to find a solution to end
the nearly nine years of violence
bringing peace to Yemen may prove
difficult as Hashem Barbara reports from
Sana
for four years U.N teams have been
patrolling areas in hadida one of the
focal points of fighting in Western
Yemen the city's boss are vital to the
economy
85 percent of the international Aid food
and Medicine arrive through here
retired General Michael Berry leads the
un's mission set up in 2019 to support
the de-escalation process in hodeidah
the fighting was heavy here back in 2020
but there was a withdrawal by the
government of Yemen forces down to the
south of the government but we are still
tasked with monitoring the ceasefire on
both sides of the front line in that
area
the U.N is also heading up efforts to
find a political solution to the nearly
nine-year conflict
its Envoy Hans Granberg and top
humanitarian coordinator David Grassley
are under pressure to end the war
a few days ago and after nearly two
years of talks Grassley managed to
convince Yemen's rival groups to agree
on a deal to avert an environmental
catastrophe off the coast of hadada I
don't want to oversell what this means
but it does show that when necessary the
parties in Conflict can find a way to
work together to deal with a common
threat and I would like to think that
the fact that they did this gives
greater confidence to other issues that
are being discussed the conflict in
Yemen took a regional turn in 2015 when
Saudi Arabia led a coalition against the
iran-backed houthis but a recent
prisoner exchange between the two is
Raising hopes of a permanent truce
The houthis Who control large area in
the north including the capital Sana
remain defiant
yemeni we want the yemeni-led debate we
don't want foreign powers to interfere I
refuse to talk to the other party when
it's under the control of the coalition
this is the man who leads the
internationally recognized government
base in Aden backed by Saudi Arabia
Russia Del alimi is struggling to expand
his influence
his biggest Challenger is this man
either Russia zubaidi who's supported by
the United Arab Emirates and wants to
establish an independent state in the
South Yemen is like no other country in
the region impoverished divided and
beset by a conflict that shows no signs
of slowing down the U.N has been trying
for years to bring together rival groups
to negotiate a settlement despite the
relative calm peace and stability are a
long way off
is the U.N Deputy humanitarian
coordinator for Yemen he joins us live
now from sana a warm welcome to you and
Yemen remains one of the world's largest
humanitarian crises 21.6 million people
still needing support what does the
humanitarian impact of the continued
failure to reach a ceasefire
well it thank you very much and thanks
for having thanks for having me
um definitely what the Yemen is a
political solution that would help
unlock all the potential of this country
the economic potential that will allow
people to resume with their lives I mean
in the meantime Yemen as you just said
yemenis continue to face a huge matter
in crisis where two-thirds of them in
2023 will need humanitarian assistance
and that is in the areas of food
assistance water assistance assistance
with health with protection and in many
other many other sectors
the crisis has also been exacerbated
though by a critical funding gaps
doesn't it I mean Yemen needs 4.3
billion dollars it's only received 1.3
billion what's going on
foreign
well we are we're monitoring I mean we
are first of all very thankful to donors
that have contributed generously over
the years to the Yemen to the year to
funding the medium response in Yemen I
mean this is out of a born out of a uh
uh
um a dynamic of solidarity which is very
much very much required but Yemen
remains one of the biggest humanitarian
crisis in the world so far this year we
have received as we said about 30 of the
funding which is more or less the same
thing we received last year and we are
continuing to uh press donors or to
request home donors to be generous
towards the women the children and the
men of Yemen as critical funding gaps do
translate into a reduction in the
assistance that we're able to that we're
able to provide how do other Global
factors impact on what's happening in
Yemen because since the war started we
of course had a cost of living crisis
we've had the crisis in Ukraine
affecting food security how do all of
these issues possibly also climactic
concerns impact on what we're seeing on
the ground in Yemen
yeah definitely I mean we are facing an
increasingly complex Global uh Global
outlook for humanitarianism and
communities have never been greater than
they are in 2023 there are new crises
that are coming that are propping up uh
you've mentioned Ukraine and we're
following the situation in Sudan that in
other in other places Afghanistan last
year too and they were discovering the
Horn of Africa that puts pressure on
donors to respond with limited uh with a
finite amount of resources to this
different crisis Yemen also is a
protracted crisis has been going on for
over uh for over eight years and there
is some uh positive news that came last
year from the truth that was signed
between uh that was negotiated by the
United Nations between the government of
Yemen and the ansarallah or the KUSI
Rebel movement that had brought forward
some hope of an improvement of the
situation that has certainly contributed
to uh
Yemen not any longer at the Forefront of
the humanitarian crisis in this world
but unfortunately our assessments of
needs of the population remain very very
high and this truth has not yet
translated into a market Improvement in
the lives of yemenis as you say there
there have been some positive
uh movement forward I suppose in
relations between the houthis and the
Saudi back yemeni government but this
clearly doesn't go far enough does it
what is the biggest obstacle to peace do
you think at the moment
well at this moment is that we need this
truce that was started in April 2022 and
that only lasted formally for about six
months and since then we're in a moment
of no peace no war but this is actually
holding back uh uh the uh this state of
indefinition is holding back the
realization of massive benefits for the
for the yemenis I mean what we hope to
see is the economy the yemeni economy to
be uh to be Unleashed to its full
potential we hope to see trade between
both parts of the countries to resume to
actually Yemen that function as a one
United economy we hope to see that some
of the measures that are being put and
that are particularly affecting
negatively the south of the country or
the Anan the government of Yemen in Aden
with the restrictions on the export of
oil will be will be lifted we hope to
see salaries being paid we hope to see
the movement of people to be afraid
throughout the country and we hope to
see investment and direct assistance
sense for development rather than only
humanitarian funding but all of this
requires a more stable political reality
and what we are hoping is that the
efforts currently being led by the
special Amboy Hans koenberg uh with the
support of countries from the region
will soon translate into a Yemen or rope
will translate into a Yemen white
political agreement that will help reap
all the benefits that I've just
described
listen it's been really uh helpful to
hear exactly how the country can move
forward and prosper hopefully in the
future if it's uh requests are fulfilled
Diego zarilla U.N Deputy humanitarian
coordinator for Yemen speaking to us
from Sana many thanks for that thanks
for joining us
thank you very much thanks for your
interest thank you